gladness is important and my superpower
would be controlling water to turn back
time change the weather whenever I want
turn a deer flock where your arm says
it's too dark to go outside it's like it
was not family say kick a puzzle
television a safe place
stop that move oh it's important to have
a bed because sometimes if you just
sleep on before without any pillows
little ants get in and they'll be all
over you I think there's kids in America
that don't go to eat much you don't get
any lunch or snack or even anything to
eat after school sad to have no books
because when you read it teaches you a
lesson and then you won't know any of
that stuff if I had magical powers I
would zap them a house food and money so
they can buy more stuff
you
a ball look Apple I would use this for
stress ball squeeze it like this right
up it and it head-on like destroying it
and then give the stuffing to like a
factory and then it turns into food you
can pinch the food and then you can eat
it you can buy a red nose and then
they'll take that money to help the kids
it's really easy to help makes me feel
happy because I get to help kids knowing
that that I did something yeah and I did
something great will make em feel happy
again
[Music]